nikki bella and artem chivinsev are
officially married yeah the two moved on
from dancing with the stars partners to
life partners i'm so blessed the
wrestler and ballroom pro share the news
in a joint instagram post on monday
they're giving fans a glimpse inside
their big day with a four-part tv
special nikki bella says i do
i want a really big bash
nikki and artem first started dating
back in 2018 nearly a year after
appearing together on the dance
competition series
[Music]
fast forward to 2019 they were engaged
i'm engaged
how crazy
the pair are parents to two-year-old son
mateo who they welcomed back in august
2020. next up bring on the wedding bells
we're gonna have some fun surprises at
our wedding and earlier this year nikki
district about planning for the big day
it is crazy with the whole wedding
planning process because it's like i
feel like you could just do it in a day
and now that i've been doing stuff yeah
i told her i'm like just right around
the corner like you need to mention i'm
like
oh my gosh and i keep asking artem did
you get your friend's information did
you get your friend's information i'm
like do you want them to be invited to
the wedding he still hasn't got me their
information yep from navigating
parenthood to finding the dress to
choosing the right venue i want to do it
right and i want it to be
like where it's a fun experience in a
journey like where it's just a lot of
fun
that's what viewers can expect to see in
that road to the altar in a special
premiering 2023 on e
i mean selfishly i just really want to
have that like one big day about me i
can't wait for that um and to wear a
dress but one of the biggest battles the
couple faces
making sure adam's loved ones can make
it
trying to figure out this whole family
thing with artem so
praying that we could get artem's family
either you know hopefully to america
soon that is our goal fingers crossed
we'll see how it all goes down on the
special
[Music]
you